100000 infizierte das befürchtet ein
britischer experte und jetzt ist das
corona virus auch in europa angekommen
frankreich hat drei fälle der
lungenkrankheit gemeldet währenddessen
will china innerhalb von wenigen tagen
eine zweite virus klinik aus dem boden
stampfen und auch in deutschland melden
sich immer mehr menschen mit
vermeintlichen symptomen in kliniken die
große herausforderung dabei die symptome
der krankheit ähneln denen einer
normalen grippe was passiert wenn es
auch hierzulande einen ersten vertrag
geht kriegs und science fiction hier
gibt es täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen in china sind
es mittlerweile 3000 menschen die mit
dem corona virus infiziert sind und die
zahl steigt weiter rasant an an einem
tag schoss die zahl der infizierten um
400 auf rund 1300 betroffene und jetzt
sind sie schon 3000 nie vergessen vom
imperial college landen vermutet
hunderttausende infizierte das große
problem anders als bei saas sind
menschen schon anstecken wenn sie keine
symptome haben laut ferguson steckt eine
infizierte person bis zu drei weitere
menschen an meine beste schätzung ist
aktuell das es schon 100.000 fälle gibt
so ferguson zum guardian auf jeden fall
liegt die zahl laut ihm zwischen 30.000
und 200.000 heute morgen könnten es
schon dreimal so viel sein und so weiter
und so fort somit hat die
lungenkrankheit jetzt alle regionen des
landes fest im griff
außer tibet 80 menschen sind bereits
gestorben und 56 millionen menschen
stehen unter quarantäne
die chinesischen behörden haben
drastische massnahmen angeordnet an
bahnhöfen busstationen und flughäfen
werden fieber messgeräte installiert
werden in johann wo das virus wohl
seinen anfang auf einem markt nahm ist
die lage kritisch den
gesundheitseinrichtungen vor ort drohen
die medizinischen hilfsmittel auszugehen
in bisher unbestätigten berichten heißt
es dass die krankenhäuser so überfordert
sind dass sie sogar kranke abweisen
müssen testverfahren und auch
schutzanzüge würden knapp weil sich das
virus hier so rasant verbreitet soll
innerhalb von wenigen tagen eine klinik
für infizierte patientinnen und
patienten entstehen die luftaufnahmen zu
diesem rasanten großprojekt sind
wirklich spektakulär das krankenhaus
soll 1300 betten fassen und wäre somit
bereits die zweite klinik vor ort die
extra wegen des virus errichtet
laut der chinesischen regierung soll vor
allem die bewegungsfreiheit der menschen
eingeschränkt werden um eine weitere
ausbreitung einzudämmen deswegen soll
die zu- und abwanderungen der leute
dringend verhindert werden dazu der
gouverneur der provinz wang qi gong wenn
dieses problem nicht gelöst worden wäre
hätte es größere schäden für leben und
gesundheit der menschen auslösen können
ab sonntag wurde in die hand des wegen
der autoverkehr weitgehend gestoppt die
größeren bezirke der elf millionen stadt
sollen für fahrzeuge geschlossen bleiben
auch die chinesische hauptstadt peking
hat den busverkehr mit den provinzen
gestoppt einige städte wurden so
komplett von der außenwelt abgeriegelt
mittlerweile hat das corona wir es auch
europa erreicht frankreich hat drei
fälle bestätigt die patienten befinden
sich in quarantäne in krankenhäusern wie
das gesundheitsministerium mitteilte
demnach geht es dem betroffenen wo gut
die französische regierung versprach
alles zu unternehmen um eine weitere
ausbreitung des erregers zu verhindern
reisen aus china sollen auf fieber und
lungenprobleme achten und bei
beschwerden umgehend den notdienst
aufsuchen aber eben das problem ist wenn
man noch keine beschwerden hat ist man
schon ansteckend und kann deshalb ganz
ungehindert weitere menschen anstecken
die eu präventions- behörde cdc stuft
die wahrscheinlichkeit als sehr hoch ein
das in europa noch weitere fälle
auftreten werden in einem offiziellen
statement von samstag heißt es zu diesem
zeitpunkt ist es wahrscheinlich dass es
mehr importierte fälle in europa geben
wird dennoch seien die europäischen
länder gut aufgestellt um einen ausbruch
nach dem entdecken zu verhindern und
unter kontrolle zu halten ende dezember
2009 10 war das corona virus erstmals in
bhutan aufgetreten wir haben darüber
ausführlich bei pixum science und
fiction hier berichtet ein
forschungsteam aus shanghai hatte dann
schnell das erbgut des virus
entschlüsselt fachleute gehen davon aus
dass es strukturelle ähnlichkeiten mit
dem sars virus hat und eben auch
ähnliche bindungsstellen im körper
benutzt um anzudocken lange zeit war man
davon ausgegangen dass coronaviren
menschen nicht wirklich gefährlich
werden können und nur normale
erkältungskrankheiten verursachen doch
die sars pandemie bewies das gegenteil
dieses werk jud respiratory syndrome
nahm 2002 seinen anfang und wird zu den
gefährlichsten infektionswellen jüngster
zeit gezählt die
weltgesundheitsorganisation who
insgesamt damals 8000 saß fälle
registriert und es gab etwa 800
todesopfer
dh dieser ausbruch war viel gefährlicher
viel tödlicher als der jetzige doch es
hätte uns eben auch damals noch viel
schlimmer treffen können
doch glücklicherweise war dieses virus
nicht so leicht übertragbar wie
beispielsweise influenza oder eben jetzt
der aktuelle corona virus ähnlich wie
das virus damals ist das corona wäre es
wohl von infizierten tieren auf menschen
übergegangen auf dem markt in buchen
waren es wohl höchstwahrscheinlich
infizierte schlangen wie jetzt ein
pekinger forschungsteam herausgefunden
hat beide schlangenarten sind im
südosten chinas häufig darunter auch in
der stadt wo hand viele patienten haben
im markt verbuchen gearbeitet wo auch
diese schlangen verkauft wurden laut der
aktuellen studie hat eine veränderung an
einem oberflächenproteinen dazu
beigetragen dass der sprung über die art
barriere zum menschen gelungen ist
gesichert gilt mittlerweile dass das
virus auch von mensch zu mensch
übertragen werden kann
die weltgesundheitsorganisation who
hatte am vergangenen donnerstag
mitgeteilt dass es schon mindestens vier
generationen des virus gibt
ausgeschlossen werden kann natürlich
nicht dass das corona wäre es auch
deutschland erreicht auch hier melden
sich immer mehr menschen mit
vermeintlichen symptomen in kliniken
diese ähneln sehr stark den symptomen
einer ganz normalen saisonalen grippe
atemwegsprobleme starkes
krankheitsgefühl und fieber doch bei dem
neuartigen corona virus kommt es nach
dem jetzigen kenntnisstand nicht zu
problemen mit den oberen atemwegen also
kein schnupfen beispielsweise ein test
wird in deutschland dann veranlasst wenn
ein patient oder eine patientin im
vorfeld in china war oder die personen
kontakt mit infizierten menschen hat er
mit hilfe eines standard verfahrens im
labor einer polymerasekettenreaktion
wird dann getestet ob die person
tatsächlich das neuartige virus in sich
trägt dazu der berliner biologe
christian drosten
die kette ist so dass natürlich zunächst
einmal ein arzt dem verdacht bekommt und
dann eine diagnostik an fordert
gleichzeitig nimmt er mit dem rötlichen
gesundheitsamt kontakt auf wenn der
labortest an ein negatives ergebnis zur
folge hat also nichts gefunden wurde
wird der fall abgeschlossen
bei einem positiven ergebnis würden die
gesundheitsämter befragung vornehmen um
herauszufinden mit wem die infizierten
kontakt hatten hier würden dann
gegebenenfalls auch labortest folgen und
möglicherweise auch eine heimquarantäne
für die kontaktpersonen angeordnet
bisher verlor
die erkrankung in den meisten fällen
mild laut den fachleuten gehen die
todesfälle in china vor allem auf ältere
menschen mit schweren vorerkrankungen
zurück fest steht aber auch eine
spezielle therapie oder eine impfung
gibt es nicht mit medikamenten können
allerdings die symptome gelindert werden
es sieht also so oder so schwer nach
einer unvermeidlichen pandemie aus
allerdings ist die todesrate gott sei
dank deutlich niedriger als zum beispiel
bei saas bisher sind vor allem eben alte
menschen mit vorerkrankungen daran
gestorben wir haben eine playlist zum
thema eingerichtet und bieten euch dort
immer wieder ab dafür hier klicken mit
allen infos anklicken anschauen und
natürlich klicks und science fiction
aber nur nieren nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts bis dann bleibt dran